(laughs)
So basically,
Tom texts me and says,
"Do you want to do
something with hovercrafts?
"Meet me here,
on this date and this time."
And here we are. I've arrived.
We don't know what we're doing.
No, neither of us know
what we're doing.
All I know is that the crew
told us both to report
to the Axceler-8 Hovercraft Centre
in... the Midlands?
Yeah, you'd call it Midlands.
Yeah.
And there's gonna be some sort of
hovercraft race, or battle, or duel.
You have done the Hoverbike.
You got two paramotors,
pointed 'em downwards,
and floated on top of it!
I know! That seemed...
This probably should have been
stage one for that project(!)
Probably why it didn't work
quite so well.
It's just one of them with
a skirt around it. You'll be fine.
Exactly. Exactly that.
Yes. Just less likely to  take your legs off.
It's a mattress motorbike.
It's like an air bed. That  goes.
You're not wrong.
You're not wrong at all!
And then it looks like
we're going to destroy a golf course.
Yep.
So...
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Plan for today:
You're gonna have a bit of a challenge.
Okay?
You need a bit of practice,
'cause we're gonna do
a bit of hovercrafting,
archery, and axe throwing.
(laughs)
Okay?
Okay! (laughs)
Bit different.
Well, I never thought you'd be saying
those words after the hovercrafting.
Right, okay!
But it's all part and parcel.
So, it's gonna be a timed session.
Yeah, this is like that Olympic thing,
where they have to go bombing
down a mountain, shoot some stuff.
Similar to it.
Yeah, only this is—
Egg and spoon race. Sack race.
(Tom and Mark laugh)
Get in your hovercraft!
So we're never doing
all three at the same time?
No.
Okay.  Alright.
You're gonna stop,
get out of the hovercraft,
do the activity, jump back in,
off you go again.
Alright.
Cool.
So the higher score you get with
your archery and your axe throwing,
the more time you get
taken off your overall score.
Yeah.
Okay?
So ideally, we want...
a quick time.
You want a quick time,
but you want maximum points.
Okay.
And then that brings all your times down.
I've got a prediction here.
I think Colin,
you're gonna go full beans
through loads of corners.
Whoa-whoa-whoa,
we don't know that yet!
And I think I'm just gonna be:
(stammers)
Right, okay guys.
Yeah?
Quick safety talk, so you know
what to do, and what not to do.
I'm gonna guess,
flipping the hovercraft.
Flipping the hovercraft... is a 'not', yeah.
Is a 'not'. Okay.
For you guys, I'm gonna get you
to stay up on your knees.
Because you can move
your body weight around easier.
Now, you've got a kill switch.
Remember, it's like a jet ski.
Yeah, lanyard.
Yeah, that's your very...
Your last point of call, let's say.
So if you're going
somewhere you don't like,
if you think something's wrong,
pull that off.
But if you do pull it off,
make sure you're still holding on.
Do they slide, obviously?
They will slide, but—
If they're going forwards, they'll slide.
If you're going sideways, they'll dig.
You've got your rudders here.
Left and right.
Push them with your fingers.
Very light, one finger.
So it's not like a go-kart.
You don't need to whack it into the corners.
So it's nice and smooth.
If you want to go to the left,
your handlebar comes back towards you.
Your weight goes onto your left knee.
If you need to, get your right knee
in the air a fraction.
So all your weight is here.
Go towards this handle.
As soon as you feel this corner
starting to push down, then you can power up.
So you can accelerate around the corner.
Right.
Okay.
If you accelerate before the corner,
you'll end up going straight through it.
If you slow down halfway around the corner,
you'll end up going out.
So you need the power
to push the back end round.
And then, you've got a throttle.
The more you squeeze that, the quicker you go.
Less you squeeze it, the slower you go.
Okay. I'll get a helmet on
and we'll give you a demo,
so you can see how easy it is to fly.
I like how you use the word 'fly'.
I like how you use the word 'easy'(!)
You're technically not on the ground,
'cause you're hovering.
Technically you're a pilot.
You're piloting a hovercraft.
'Cause you are seven inches
off the floor with these.
Oh, it goes up that— Well...
How far does the skirt sit off the ground?
About seven inches.
Does it?
Yeah. So you will see—
I thought you just skimmed it off.
When you're going full speed, I guess.
No, that's an airboat.
Come on. I wanna see it.
Let's see it.
♪ (rock guitar)
(motor turns on)
(motor revving)
(rock music builds)
(music stops)
(engine turns off)
If you say— If you say,
"That's all there is to it," I swear!
That's all there is to it!
(engine turns on)
Right. Go.
♪ (slow, heavy rock music)
Well, he's turning!
Yeah. In the right sort of position,
so that's okay.
I mean, he nailed the
first half of that, didn't he?
(engine slowing)
(engine turns off)
Like a duck to water!
I should say, it's a bit weird.
I wouldn't say—
Woah! I mean,
pressure's on me now here.
'Cause that was, you just went!
(laughs)
You can tell I'm not
used to safety equipment.
He's trying to take off the helmet.
He can't get the helmet off.
I can't get the bloody helmet off!
(laughs)
Is there a—
I got it.
Oh, what was that?
It's got a little clip latch.
Just a little tab.
Not used to that.
Alright.
Fine, Tom Scott. Go for it.
(groans)
(music resumes)
Yeah, okay.
(engine turns on)
(engine accelerating)
(laughs)
Ooh, where you going, Tom?
Power, power, power.
There you go.
I'd watch him, Jamie, if I was you.
He's coming for you. (laughs)
I think for a bit of a
social media clip...
we should have Tom here,
me standing behind him
with my shirt and tie on,
and then he just revs it,
and I go like that.
So it's like, tie and hair everywhere.
(music ends)
This has not gone well!
(laughs)
(engine turns off)
Right, look at your position again.
I'm way further back!
You've gone further back down the seat,
and when you're trying to get
around the corners, you're doing it like that.
You've got to do it like that.
Right.
So that's the key thing.
Your body weight:
70 percent of your steering.
I mean, I've gotta make up
the points over there.
I'm gonna have to make up
points over there.
When you throw these,
you kinda want a strong, straight wrist
as much as you can.
So what you're trying to go for is
straight and parallel.
Best way to throw them
is to 'chop', is what I like to call it.
So in that kind of— Right.
Yeah.
You're taking it up, taking it back,
and then you're chopping it forward.
Oh, a full over-arm— Okay.
Pretty much.
You want that elbow
up by the side of your head,
and you wanna chop it
forward like that.
In terms of it—
'Cause I've always thought
axe throwing is more about like,
if it's spinning 'round,
it's only gonna stick in
if it's coming 'round like that?
So you've got to get the
amount of rotations right, or else...
You know, you'll hit the board,
but it ain't gonna stick in the board.
So yeah, all of that stuff matters.
It's speed, about the spin
that you get on it.
To be honest, if these hit the board,
Colin, it'll be a miracle.
But I'll see what I've got. Alright.
So, you start with the other leg forward.
You're going up, back, and throw.
♪ (pulsing rock music)
There we go.
And if you shuffle about a little bit as well,
that's just a guide.
So, little steps forward,
little steps back will help.
Let's have a go at one of these.
Oh god, okay.
(music fades)
I've found my weapon of choice!
(Tom and Colin laugh uproariously)
Wow!
Will you look at that?
Three for three, on the target.
Thumbnail, thumbnail!
(laughs)
Okay, guys. The final challenge
is gonna be archery.
Yeah.
Okay.
So: arrow, bow, target.
Yeah. Okay, right.
That's where we need to be going.
The arrow goes in...
into the nock on the string.
Hang on, I can't see it.
Where's— Oh, okay.
Oh, that's what they mean
when on...
When they're on the wall
at King's Landing, they shout, "Nock!"
Oh yeah, arrow in the nock.
Yeah, arrow in the nock.
And then it goes onto this little...
Little thingy there.
...little lever.
Now, with this...
the arrows aren't massively long,
so you don't need to pull it back too far.
So you're gonna pull it
back here, okay?
Keep your fingers out of the way.
Back to your nose.
When you're on target, or you think
you're on target, then you just release.
Nice and straight.
Eyy!
I'll give you that one(!)
In fairness, that was in a gust as well.
So you've got to
allow for the wind to travel.
Right.
Okay. I'll give you that.
Tell you what, we'll make a point
so you both stand in the same place.
So just put your hip
on the side of the table.
Ooh, fairness is fairness.
Alright, alright.
Ohh!
Got it.
Five seconds?
So that's five seconds off your time.
So that's okay.
Go on then, Tom.
Alright. I assume this is
a bow specifically designed
for people who've never
done this before, 'cause...
Yeah, it's a beginner's bow.
Yeah. (chuckles)
I feel like we've got
training wheels on all day today.
Ohh, I mean, I'll take 'em frankly.
Right, okay, so.
Get your arm nice and straight.
Arm straight.
Yeah, pull it back.
(light twang)
Pfft! It's not a good start, that.
Don't forget this is timed.
Well yes, I do realise that.
Oh, is it?
Yeah. The whole thing's timed.
The whole thing's timed?
Still on the clock.
Oh he's— Oh.
So...
We gotta get—
We're gonna get a stitch halfway through.
Keep going, keep going, bit more.
♪ (slow, heavy rock music)
Right to there.
Better. Felt better.
Felt better. Yeah.
I've been watching
Game of Thrones all week.
(Tom and Mark chuckle)
Wo-o-o-ah!
Twenty!
Yeah.
Good, solid shots again.
Got his eyes in there.
One, two, three.
There we go!
It shouldn't feel like this is
about confidence of going,
"Oh yeah, this is
what I need to do", but...
Two, three.
Well, I'm not sure I'm gonna hit it,
but the arrows are at least flying now.
I am now at the point you were
with your first shot, so I'll take that.
(music stops)
So, all we've got to do is...
...in the hovercraft,
round the course...
...fire some arrows,
round the course again...
Yeah.
...throw some axes,
to the finish line.
There's a lot—
a lot to go wrong.
And currently, you're better
at every element of this.
No, oh wait!
Your axing's on par with mine.
With the middle ones, I'd say.
Yeah, that's fair.
I think archery's down to the weather.
No, what I've got to rely on here
is you getting overconfident
and making a catastrophic error!
Which has happened
many times in the past!
(both laugh)
Right, shall we have some sandwiches?
(group laughing)
And then we'll attack it.
Let's do it.
I get emails sometimes
asking how to learn to code.
I started learning that about 30 years ago,
so my answer's always been, "Ehh?"
But today's video sponsor
is Boolean,
and if you're thinking a career in tech
might be for you,
you might want to check them out.
To be clear, Boolean are a
career-focused tech academy.
Live, online classes with
actual teachers and coursework,
taught by people who've done the job
and have industry experience.
Their courses last between
10 weeks and 6 months, full-time or part-time.
You can choose between front-end development,
full-stack, or data analytics.
It's not just "type in your credit card
for a monthly subscription".
It's a commitment.
There's an application process.
They will have a call with you,
before you sign up,
to make sure that they're right for you
and you're right for them.
It's designed to get you a job,
and you have the option to pay afterwards,
once you get hired.
If you're looking to start
a career in tech,
then head to the link in the description,
and check out the courses.
And if you're not sure,
there's a free Fundamentals Camp
that can get you from zero,
to building a website.
That's pre-recorded,
but it'll show you how Boolean works.
Oh, and if you do go for it
and apply for the full thing,
then mention that you found out about them
from me in your admissions interview.
They will knock £500
off the cost of the course.
The link is in the description.
Right, back to the show!
Okay guys,
you've done your practice.
Now is the challenge.
(laughs)
So, we're gonna start from
where we're standing.
We're gonna go this way...
around the red flag,
straight across the water,
around the next red flag,
through the yellow gate, through the blue gate,
360 on this red flag,
through the blue flag, nice little curve,
stop before the archery, jump out,
fire your bow three times,
jump back in,
back between these two flags,
then you've got four white posts,
straight through the first two white posts.
That takes you into a hairpin bend.
Straight back down the little straight.
Back between these two yellows,
come back between the two blue flags,
then you go down to the two yellows
at the bottom of the hill.
That'll bring you out to those two blue flags.
Go up the field to the top red flag,
come around that red flag,
straight back down,
and that's when you come back
between all the flags, and then you stop here.
But if you hit the flags,
you get five seconds each flag.
So you gotta get the hovercraft
between the flags without touching them.
Once you stop here,
you jump out, go and get your axes,
one-two-three,
the balloons should disappear.
(sighs)
I have a feeling
this is a course designed
for people who are
better at all these things(!)
We're starting here.
Yeah.
We're going around that.
Let's just run it, Tom!
Yep, we loop around
the outside of this flag.
We hope.
I'm not gonna try and do that.
Over the pond.
And then it's around that flag there.
This red one.
Like we've normally done.
After we've done this snakey one here,
do we go blue-yellow
or straight around to yellow?
Yeah, blue-yellow!
Yeah, it is blue-yellow.
Of course it's blue-yellow(!)
All the way up to the top.
Then there's a right-hand around that bend.
And then you're in home with the greens.
Yeah.
Well, apart from the...
two, four, six, eight, ten flags,
you can get 50 seconds over there.
Whew.
So... we do that course.
Five seconds added for
each flag we hit.
Yeah.
Ten seconds off for each balloon we pop.
Yeah. And then—
And every point on that target
is a second off.
Yeah.
You've got this in the bag.
You've got this in the bag!
No, no, come on!
Oh and also, if we go the wrong way...
there is some...
You're just gonna look at it
and think how much...
how much time
do you think he saved.
Just so you're not cheating,
we're gonna make sure that
you are following the course.
Yeah, we'll do our best!
I know you will.
Who wants to go first?
I'll— I'll—
I'm not— I'm not fussed.
So... let's...
I'll...
I think I'm gonna be the slow one here.
So I'm gonna go first.
I'm gonna give you a time to beat.
Yeah.
I'll get a helmet. Here we go!
Right, Tom's going first.
♪ (action rock groove)
Ready.
(motor turns on)
That's right, ladies and gentlemen.
Here we go!
Colin Furze vs Tom Scott.
Hovercraft, axe throwing, and archery race!
He's off! It's a good start!
Lean, Tom.
Lean, lean, lean.
So this is a good start from Tom.
See, I didn't think
this was gonna be about speed.
I think the faster we try and go,
the more of a mess we're gonna get in.
Alright, we got our first hit!
Oh, we got another hit.
We're going for the 360.
This is where it all starts
to get tricky!
Is he gonna get around it?
Yeah, he got around it!
See, Tom's great at memorising stuff.
And that's an advantage
he's definitely got on me.
Finger above!
Come on, Tom.
If you're gonna hit the target,
this is the time to hit the target.
Oh, so close!
Nearly, yeah.
Come on, you need to get 30 points.
(Tom and Mark groan)
Not quite, not quite.
He's getting back in again now.
(motor accelerating)
Yeah, I mean, he cut the corner.
But like we said before, there's no pegs
on the inside corner, so it don't matter.
Oh, now this is the tricky bit.
Oh, he's... totally overshot that!
He's just drifting around.
Like Fast and Furious 15,
Tom Scott!
Well, he sorta got through 'em!
I think he's doing alright, you know.
There's a bit of pressure on here.
Oh, I thought he was
going home then! (laughs)
Right, he's just got the green ones to go.
He's pretty good.
This is a tricky bit, this is.
And... stopped.
Right, get ready, axe throwing.
I'm getting out of the way.
...Oh!
(music ends)
Stop the clock!
Three balloons. There's a happy man.
Three balloons with two axes!
I think that's a good run!
Right, I'm gonna have a pre-match
nervous wee, and then it'll be my turn!
(group laughing)
♪ (upbeat rock music)
(engine revving)
Oh, that is fast and that is solid!
He's got that.
God, I'm being hustled here!
He's absolutely nailed it.
He's gone early... oh!
One centimetre there!
I'm a little mad about it.
(engine decelerating)
He didn't so much hit that flag
as obliterate it, but...
He's straight in the archery,
alright, what's he got?
Weird with the bloody visor up, isn't it?!
Close, close!
Whoa!
He's hit the bloody target.
Might have to give you one for that.
(groans)
Is that any time off
Now, is he gonna remember
which way to go?
Yes, through the blues.
And he's remembered the left turn.
He's gone into it plenty early.
Ah!
He's nailed it!
Right, he should be going
full throttle here.
The question is, how many flags
does he obliterate on the slalom?
'Cause I got at least one of each pair.
Ohh!
One!
Two!
(music ends)
Three.
There's no—
We don't need the times, Colin.
You've got that one.
I dunno.
I did hit more flags,
I think, than you.
Colin, you just did the slalom flawlessly!
You didn't hit a single flag!
I bet there's not a lot in that.
Well... let's go to the judges.
Okay Greg, what were the final scores?
Right, so Tom,
your original time...
was 4:27.88.
That sounds— That sounds slow.
4:27 sounds—
I don't know, I don't know.
And Colin, your original time
was 3:22.5.
A minute and five!
I knew you were faster!
Alright, so—
But wait a minute, I did hit—
No, I hit— I hit—
The only way— That's 65 seconds.
'Cause we matched on that,
we matched on that.
The only way I can
pick up 65 seconds is if...
you hit thirt— fourteen more flags!
You need to have hit
every flag on the course.
Right. And your score, Tom, with penalties...
is 4:57.88.
So wait, I only hit six?
No, you hit twelve.
Five seconds each, sorry.
And then Colin, your final score
was 3:42.43.
So what did I—
My maths is gone.
You hit ten flags.
Ten flags. Yeah.
I thought you hit less than that.
I think you did that bit
around there better than me.
So I only hit two more than him?
You only hit two more.
Thank you, Colin!
Cheers, Tom.
Thank you Mark, Chloe, Greg.
Yeah, you're just good at this stuff.
I'm glad I've won.
(laughs)
I always worry about these things.
There's always a certain
level of expectation for some reason.
Yeah.
But...
There we are. That's good.
Right, I'm gonna have another go.
(group laughing)
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]